[Music]
Lord Sun dawns on the day called seven
monkey his fingers slowly spreading a
rosy sheen that mixes softly with smoke
rising from tonight it lands many hearth
fires the Midwife shocked roughtly has a
difficult choice to make a momentous
shift from rainy season to dry season is
underway all summer the gods have kept
the people fed with corn but the Fertile
summer months are disappearing this day
occurs during the festival that marks
the shift between the summer season when
the gods feed the people and the winter
season when the people feed the gods in
return
sure quietly owes a debt to her patron
to Teo anon the female warrior goddess
at the center of this festival today Oh
anon wages war both on women's
battlefields of birth and in men's
battles with - not to eat lands enemies
she must be kept happy or she will bring
bad luck
the Midwife should participate in the
festival today but one of her patients
could go into labor any minute
she quietly decides to check on her
patient first the expecting mother
hasn't worked too hard to drum or lifted
heavy things
her family is taking good care of her
surely sure quietly can take a little
time to honor her goddess she leaves her
apprentice in charge and heads to the
center of the city along the way she
sees women sweeping the roads and
hanging gourds in preparation for the
festival finally she reaches the great
pyramid on top are two temples the north
where rituals honor the rain God in the
summer and the south one is where
rituals honor the war God in the winter
on the equinox the Sun rises between the
two sides the ceremony begins with a
mock battle between the midwives and the
other physicians truck route Lee's team
battles heartily throwing not sleep
marigolds and balls made of reed and
moss they joke call their rivals names
are laugh but then a girl comes running
with a message for sure quietly her
patient is in labor she hurries back to
the house all the old women from the
extent
family have already gathered for the
birth their experience is very valuable
if anything goes wrong she readies
herself with a prayer praising her most
important tools her fingers then she
doses the patient with sewer partly to
help expel the baby massages her in
sweat house and rubs her stomach with
tobacco offering to Teo in an a short
prayer she urges her patient to act like
a warrior a strong baby girl slips into
her waiting hands and the old woman's
shout triumphant cries shock roughtly
takes a few drops of water from a jade
bowl breathes on them and places them on
the baby's tiny tongue she calls her a
precious green stone a little warrior
and tells her how the Lord and Lady of
the night sky breathed life into her
sending her to this place of burden and
torment she then turns to the new mother
praising her telling her she acted like
an eagle warrior a Jaguar warrior by the
time they finish it's late and the
flames of the fire have died down chakra
tree piles the remaining hot coals in
the center of the hearth stoking them to
keep them going she lays the baby in a
woven basket head facing the warming
fire this will warm her turn Ally an
important soul center in the body
central to health and well-being it's
almost midnight ashore quietly hurries
she can get back to the temple for the
culmination of the festival she makes
her way to the city center where a
priest carries a woman on his back to
the top of the pyramid to begin the new
season and feed the gods she will be
beheaded symbolizing her corn is cut in
the fields afterward she will be reborn
as lady to tale anon
and preside over the induction of new
warriors go back in time to the capital
of ancient Egypt to see how the doctor
peso chat tends to her patients ailments
or dive deeper into Aztec culture with
the myth of how the week and pimply
naina wat became Lord Sun
[Music]